well i
see that quite a few people have joined
so i think i'm going to start
and for those who have just joined my
name is daria parechna
and i work with blockchain
team in wolfram research south america
that i'm not in south america but that's
my team
um and i'm working on cryptography
functionality
so it's not just blockchain it's
more general failed but we do provide uh
basis for also our blockchain projects
and yesterday christian was doing a
talking blockchains if you want to
rebroadcast that
but i am doing cryptography and
cryptography in wolfram language
has started around version 10 if i'm not
mistaken
was things like encrypt
decrypt decryption of files
generation of keys and
another encryption algorithms then since
then we have ground quite a lot
you see that this list is only becoming
longer
we have added digital signatures we have
added
elliptic curves keys and signatures
and we have added file signatures
system credential a lot of stuff
and since today i'm gonna be talking
mostly about stuff that we've been
adding for the last year since the last
conference
and this is going to be almost
everything new involved too
the abstract you have already seen it's
been on the meeting page
but so what's new in cryptography
n12 is that we have more
support for more elliptic curves since
the first one that we've added
has done so good we decided it's a good
way to go
we have added another digital signature
algorithm which
is snore digital signatures
so now we have three different digital
signature algorithms in total
which are rsa elliptic curve
the standard elliptic curve ecdsa and
schnorr
uh a big thing for new involved two is
going to be import of
bam files and we try to do our best
there and i'm going to show you examples
and the to that
a symbolic representation of
certificates to make them computable
and to make people able to do operations
involved from language
with certificates so
let's go
biolipticus so and version 12o
if i'm not mistaken we have added
elliptic curve cryptography
to the wall from language and we have
started was
the scarf ccp256 k1
which is probably one of the most
famous curves that exist because it's
the one that
bitcoin is based on and ethereum and
a lot of other blockchains as well so to
support that we have added
a key generation one of the curves
and the default if you ask for elliptic
curve is going to be this one
because that's the one more used and in
health 2 we have added
a few more and until the release there
might be a few more again
right now we have six different
so this one is 256 bets
long this one is a little bit longer
a little bit more secure and then this
one is twice as long
so if you want to set up a higher
security even
than the one that is used in bitcoin you
can use this one
and just specify that to generate a
symmetric key pair if you want to
now be able to generate a curve with a
specific name you can just
set the curve name option to this name
of the curve
and it's going to generate let's say
this one
which is longer and there is also a
shorthand notation without having to
specify map advice to type
in c1 you just say method goes to
the curve name and it's going to
generate you
a key pair of private and public key
based on this curve
with needed lengths and need parameters
now once you have the keys based on this
curve you can just pass
them to generate digital signature
without having to specify any method
here
or curve name again it's just going to
automatically generate signature
using the correct one that you have
specified
um so right now we only have six curves
and in the wild there are many more i
think open ssl supports
around 30 maybe a few more
but we're going to get there and
so this is what's going to be available
in 12 2.
this next thing that is new
as schnorr digital signatures and i
think that
has already came out in 12.1.1
but this wasn't announced in the last
year's conference so i'm saying it again
and for this one i can actually use the
keys that we have generated on the
previous page
and you see it has automatically taken
the curve
from the key but the type of signature
has
changed to schnorr
and here it was a
type of signature elliptic curve
in the bottom
and here is schnorr once you specify
type goes to noir
and snore is
the algorithm that was invented a couple
of decades ago
but now it's gaining a lot of this fame
because uh it's more secure than just
the classical ecdsa
because you can private uh it's probably
secured means
you can mathematically pref that is
secure
and it allows for a multi-party
signing which means that
not only me with my private key i can
send this message
also that if there are three of us
and we want to sign the same message
like for example
um you know when there are two of you
and you're buying an apartment
and you and a bus sign the contract uh
schnorr signatures are the only ones
that allow
to combine private keys in a way
that creates a signature that is based
and verifiable
on all of these keys
which was one of the reasons for us to
also add
this to the orphan language
then the big thing that we have been
working
a lot with this the one that we have
spent most
time for this new version is
the import of pm files and pm files
are uh one of the standard ways of
storing and exchanging of cryptographic
data
which are keys certificates
encrypted data sign data
lots of things and
it helps too we're going to be able to
import them in a very nice symbolic form
so just to give you an idea the usual vm
file for those who don't know
looks something like this so it has a
title begin
end it says here it's a private key
and then it has a sort of encoded
structure that is
for humans absolutely understandable
but it's an encoded sequence of bytes
that have values
in one file you can have multiple of
those blobs
inside and wolfman which can import
all of them um the biggest that i saw
for example in linux you can go to
the repository contains certificates in
your computer
and put them all in one file and there's
going to be a few hundred of them
and all for english can import them into
like even file that bag
so i'm now going to show you what this
new version is able to do with
this file
so magically involved too a file that
looks like this
turns itself into a private key
the private key hat that we use by
default
um you can go and
see
[Music]
what's actually inside what are
the values that have been
imported and you see that
from this blob we've been able to
understand that
this is based on this curve
and this is the public key and this is
the private key
that is not uncompressed and
we have also provided them as a byte
array for
convenience
so now you have this file and you might
have gotten it
generated from another program you might
have gotten it
generated by yourself and what's cool is
that
you can just import it and use it on
wall from language
without having to use generate a
symmetric key pair
to every time generate a new session
once you have this key saved
you don't have to worry that it's going
to get lost
it's just there and you can import it
anytime you need it
you can compute its public key and
you've seen that in the file that was
now public key
you can easily compute it and go for
language already and now you can use
them as a pair
for example for signing
um assume i have this
file i have created this document and i
want to digitally sign it
by saying that it's actually me the
owner of the ski
who was able to sign this document
and with generate file signature i can
do so
and it gives me additional signature
and anyone who has my public key
can just go and verify that that is
actually true that i have
signed this file was my
private key
now as i've just said
i've said this phrase i am the owner of
this private key
and uh for you as yours right now there
is no way to verify that
it's just something that i claim which
might as well not be true because in the
modern age of internet
nobody trusts no one and
so if you know you reserve this file
with the signature with somebody who
claims to be me
and says oh well i have signed this file
this information
you can verify it it's true it's correct
you don't have to believe
and because of this problem because
remotely people were not able to
actually prove that i am who i am
claimed to be
and that this key is the one that i am
claiming to be my key
emerged a thing called public
infrastructure
and the thing called certificates
the a certificate as a sort of
proof that the party who is
the owner of the private key is actually
the ones that they claim to be
and that is usually verified by a
trusted
third party or a trusted agency it can
be a government agency it can be a
private agency
that gives certificates
to people so the certificate
for example let me show you
what it is the certificate is a
structured standardized
thing that has several standard fields
in it
one very important field is actually who
it was issue two
this was issued to a test client not
that exciting
by whom by open ssl
test ca and we assume we trust of an ssl
who has issued the certificate
it has a validity so it's still valid
it's fine
and a lot of other useful files
[Music]
and this file looks exactly as the one
that we have
just looked at it's a header
and a lot of weird bites inside
some of them also have a blob on top
and in waffle language we are now able
to
decrypt sort of decode this
into this very nice structure
and you can query this object for public
key if you need it you can query
for its serial number you can get the
signature out of it
and you can compute with them anything
you need and this is a
very specific piece of cryptographic use
mostly
intended uh for um
supporting this sort of public key trust
infrastructure between parties who
actually do not trust each other but
with certificates
they can and just to preview
how versatile you have made the subject
to be
i'm going to show an example that is a
little bit complicated
but it just showcases everything we need
so a certificate is to give you an idea
of this
as a certificate from wolfram.com and
this is for example if you go to
wolfram.com website
and in browser you set as little
log it's a certificate valid
and you go to details the certification
pass
you see if there is a certificate that's
the one
above it in the chain so this one
is the authority that has issued the
certificate to wall from and modesty
it's already has issued a certificate to
that associate that has issued
a tool from and we can import that
example when you say copy to file
we plan to do that directly from the url
but so far you can import it as base
encoded
but for your convenience i have already
copied this into this iconized
little blob here you see it's quite big
one
has seven thousand characters
so you're going to have it in the
presentation notebook if you want to
play around with it
and we are able to
import all of them the whole letter
and you can see that this the first one
was issued to wolfram by
god a secure authority then the one
below was issued to go daily secure
austerity
by go ready red authority then the next
one was issued to the root
by godaddy grip incorporated and then
the last one was
issued by godaddy grip to go to do group
itself
so the last one on the chain is called
the red
and this is called this whole thing is
called a certificate chain
and now that our browser connects to
wolfram.com
they receive this chain and they receive
the certificate
they see that it's valid and
they know that connecting to wolfram.com
is safe
that the wolfram.com website they were
trying to connect is actually the one
that it's claiming to be
and not some scam somebody who tries to
pretend to be wolfram.com that we don't
have to trust
and just for the convenience let's
name them first second certain red so we
don't have to do
part every time and let's just check
that this chain is actually valid
and we can do all of that
programmatically for example
first of all the obvious thing that
comes to mind
let's check that every one
of the states in the chain that says
valid before
that every one of the valid before dates
is actually
after now and that's true
so good so far so good
um we can check that certificates do in
fact form a chain
which means that the issue
of the first certificate and we can look
at it so
it's united states arizona
scottsdale is good incorporated issued
the certificate
to wolfram
and to form a chain the certificates
have to have that the second
certificate as the subject
the one that has issued the first
certificate
and we see that they're the same
so this is that's two certificates of
list
do you have form a chain of trust
and was think like moving map we can
just go
to it retrain good they actually do for
a machine
press which means that every next
certificate is issued
by every previous one
we can check i see some questions coming
in
and i think i'm going to answering them
later
after after i finish
going through this so
um we can check that the last
certificate is red
which for red it's both
the issue and the subject that sort of
certifies itself and it's true
and what we could also see that in the
extensions
read um
you see we can parse all the extensions
we can get the criticality flags
we can get the data where it's relevant
to be binary
or whether it's relevant to be an
association or where it's relevant to be
just an integer
and in this case we can see that this
particular red
has certificate as already goes to trail
so
it is an authority that can issue
certificates
which is exactly what we expect to be
which is good then
on to something even more complicated
you can query any field from the
certificate so to check
[Music]
that we take the public key after it
we can take the actual signed bytes
and let's just for a second look at the
red
so this digital signature means
that the the vet the the actual
issue of the certificate has taken all
the bytes
of the certificate and they have signed
us with this public key
and that's what they claim to and that's
what we're trying to check here
and at school that we have integrated
all of this
into the our existing functions so test
returns as a digital signature
just the way that we use it internally
and you can actually just feed that to
verify digital signature
it's going to tell you it's trip and we
can also check
that the same way for every
certificate in the chain therefore the
other certificates
they have to be signed by the issuer
so for example the first certificate has
signed data
it has digital signature but it has to
be signed
by the second one so the public key
comes from the second one and that's
again we can do
with the movie map
that takes the sign data from the first
one signature from the first one but the
key
from the second one it just goes up the
chain
and it gives us all fifth and that's
in many other wonderful things
you can do with the certificates
and i have barely made it on time to
leave you
some time for questions
i can talk about this for hours so
feel free to keep asking another chat
later
or shoot me an email
and you're gonna have this notebook
you're gonna have all the documentation
for the things that you can go
with so i think the best recommendation
is already in the belt
yeah so you can familiarize yourself
even more now
there were questions
so there was one question here in zoom
is the support
for key store planned
if you mean the key store as in
system keychain i think we do
already have that
it's called system credential
and system credential
creates a key that you can actually
store
i'm sorry i'm not aware about java
keystore
but the cs12 files we are planning to be
able to read
and what about java i'm not sure i can
answer
your question right now um
how would i go about signing a notebook
and embedded in the notebook
so right now you will have to just sign
in a book and send
the signature along with the notebook
it's not yet possible to embed it inside
but it's certainly something we are
considering
but this would be a big project
so it actually has to be convincing to
everyone because we need a front-end
grip
and we need a lot of people to be
working on it
but i'm glad you asked because that sort
of project i am trying to
actually make life and i think it's
going to be very useful to people
to be able to embed the signatures in
the wolfram files that they're creating
and right now we already have basically
everything we need for that we have the
signatures we have the notebooks we have
the hash we have the actual things
and so i think this
actually has future and it might happen
at some point
right now for example if
we are going to here i've assigned the
file
so if i would publish this or file to
cloud
i can publish the signature along with
it and
people can download about stem and
verify you know by just getting cloud
cloud get from cloud object
but this is certainly something that i
personally think
should be done because it's going to be
useful to people
because we as well from are a part
of a lot of you know research
institutions
that i mean our users are part of
research institutions
and i think it's going to be useful for
them to be able to sign the files
actually
embedding their credentials
um are there any plans to have
a system interchangeable private keys
available from cloud
not yet but we have to design that this
is a part of the saying
um of the previous question basically
so to to allow people to have a
verifiable
system of embedding their credentials
into notebooks
and having other people be able to check
that
we all need to design this
infrastructure
inside wolfram but am i going to get to
ask
because it's good to see that people are
actually interested in that
and might give us more fuel to
actually go and do that project because
that is going to be a major one
um okay and
any last questions
okay then i think everyone has
by now asked what they wanted um
please feel free to keep asking once you
can get a chance to go through the
notebook
and i appreciate your comments and i
appreciate
suggestions about what people
want to see in our cryptography
infrastructure
sort of and welcome language because
that will give us
more priority on which things we need to
look at
first and which direction we should keep
developing our project and uh
thank you all for coming to my talk
today
and enjoy the rest of your conference
in enjoy thanks